hello everybody I hope that you are good
I'm quite happy to be honest because
last night right before going to bed I
saw that yesterday's projection got
completed
so that was such a good feeling okay to
see how your trade closes right before
bed you can ask for more than that to be
honest because you don't have to you
know wake up and check uh how the trade
went if you're the stop loss got hit or
if you are in profit or if you're close
to position with your take profit no
just go to bed
with the position closed it's absolutely
perfect so anyway uh yesterday we saw
this production completed and it was a
push up above the 50ma retraceable
support here two candles testing of
support you can see the rejection with
those weeks so that's you know pretty
much everything you want to see two
candles perfect you're going to ask for
more and then the continuation to the
next liquidity pool okay then this was
right at the start of the Asian session
in the first hour you guys can see uh
well in the first two hours and then we
had a rejection okay
well let me remove this but I think what
they did here okay with this retrace was
to fill some of this imbalance some of
these large green candle but I think
that our I'm telling you again I don't
see any reason why there are there is
not going to be continuation in fact
what I feel half a lot of lines here let
me remove some because I'm going crazy
here okay I like my charts nice and
clean you know me so you know we went
into this liquidity pool of course the
liquidity pool is not finished this zone
is not fully taken yet you can see that
we still have 29 650 could be taken or
even 30 350. so I think that we are not
finished in this one and also they left
an imbalance yesterday you can see in
one hour time frame this long week okay
that goes from
29 326 all their way to 29 530 and if
you go to the 15 minutes time frame it's
even longer check this out okay so what
I want to expect the price comes today
to fill this week so we're gonna again
favor long positions okay that's you
know it's not Financial advice that's
how I'm reading the market
um we'll see if if it happens or not but
but yes I'm expecting that we'll come
back to this week today
um let me see where we are what is
holding the 50ma in the 15 minutes time
frame which is a a good sign to be
honest and in the one hour time frame
you know with this here as support this
must have been also the four hours time
frame that we suggested this is when we
enter the trade in this one here also
check this week's how they get filled
okay before push it higher and I like to
say that because it's basically telling
me
that they are not living big imbalances
behind so then I can truce this move so
that's basically another Confluence
another reason why I think that we are
not finished in this Zone and we might
continue going higher I think at least
today we could see 29 500 all right but
it's very likely that we see that we
also see even the whole Equity pool
finish now you have to keep in mind on
today is Friday
we have the weekend you know in front of
us so I'm not expecting you know that
the push continues over the weekend like
this I'm not gonna tell you that that's
going to happen because I will be lying
to you I don't think that's going to
happen then it might happen then I may
be wrong now but it usually happens
usually what you're gonna see during the
weekend is a range okay you're gonna see
something like this
something like this then on Monday
no matter some kind of false move
and then during the week you might see
the rest of the move I mean we see that
pretty much every single week check this
out uh this is the weekend range here I
would say we can range roles you can
range one hour time frame
let me try to find it
um Saturday and Sunday so I would say
the from here
all right
this was your weekend range then we had
well you know it was the weekly the
weekly candle on Sunday but it was also
the monthly candle so then you see some
kind of volatility it's in the evening
okay that's that's completely normal but
then you see
you have the weekend range then you have
the false move or Monday and then the
rest of the week you're going to the
opposite direction okay and that's
something that we see quite often to be
honest in this game and I call it a game
obviously it's not a game it's a lot
more than a game it's you know my job
but
um Ending game has rules and it has you
know it moves in a certain way uh if you
watch Barcelona playing you know the
weather gonna play the same as if I
watch the Bitcoin chart
I try to understand how it's going to
move
let me check the SMP chart because it's
really the only thing that makes me
worried in the context that if it makes
a move maybe Bitcoin follows okay and
you can see that we're in a Range we've
had several deviations above and below a
lot of deviations last night we had one
then we pumped because after the market
closed we had Apple's earnings reports
and they were better than expected as
you know guys apple is the biggest stock
in the SMP so if apple is pumping the
SMP in theory should be you know
um influenced by it and maybe continue
that pump now today we have some
important data coming out and it's the
non-farm payroll okay it's basically
about the labor market and that's going
to be in 15 minutes I just posted on
Twitter I warning that you know don't
trade until until then you know close
all your trades and then after that
let's see how the results are let's see
how the market react and then we can
trade again we can then go back to
bitcoin let's go back to bitcoin second
Bitcoin here
this one go to the one hour time frame
and let's see how they simply reacts
probably Bitcoin should follow because
imagine if you for example see you know
quite a bad results uh for the market
then maybe you can say Bitcoin
completing the move of this liquidity
pool here and then there will be a
better entry point than now okay to this
new liquidity ball to this week and the
landing liquidity pool
anyway guys I want to keep you nice and
short I hope that you enjoyed the update
thank you so much for watching and I'll
see you soon